[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about theory which none of the
living characters who followed in the
series is azor Ahai because the
principles promised was rhaegar
targaryen then his brother and John's
father who died during Robert's
rebellion George Arman has skin it is
before when he said that he always
wanted to write a story where the
grandeur of the story dies or loses at
the beginning and the aftermath of it
his ears have gone with no additional
input from George Arman himself fans
have gotten very creative in theorizing
about Jon Snow or Danni being the
prophesied Savior some are even claiming
that supporting characters like the
Hound about surviving injury are azor
Ahai but if this theory that I'm going
to introduce within this video is true
then the prince has already come and
gone and nobody even noticed according
to this theory Jon Snow may not be as
high although he might still have
connection to the prophesied savior of
Westeros for those unfamiliar with the
prophecy here's the quick version during
the first long night centuries ago a
hero named azor Ahai saved Westeros from
death and chaos by driving the White
Walkers far into the North using a
flaming sword Lightbringer
according to ancient prophecies that
were written down in a shy over 5,000
years ago following along summer when
the Stars bleed and the cold breath of
darkness falls heavy in the world
authorized to be reborn and destined to
defeat the darkness once again it says
that Westeros a champion will return as
the prince that was promised being
reborn amid smoke and salt to wake
dragons from stone and reforged a great
sword Lightbringer the defeated the
darkness those thousands of years ago if
all tales are true a terrible weapon
forged with a loving wife's heart great
power requires great sacrifice here's
the exacting written in the ancient book
of a shy
there'll come a day after a long summer
when the stars bleed and the cold breath
of darkness falls heavy in the world in
this jetta or a warrior's shoujo from
the fire a burning sword and that sword
shall be Lightbringer
the red sword of heroes and hero class
say shall be azor Ahai come again and
the darkness shall flee before him
if azor Ahai is the same as prince that
was promised he is born the line of
aries ii and Rolla
and he or she is the Song of Ice and
Fire according to Rhaegar Targaryen most
fans believed is here to be Energon or
Danny and I see why there are too many
clues a hint supporting both after long
Samuraizer Kai will be reborn amidst
assault prophecy says this could point
on Jon's resurrection he was reborn
after he was stabbed to death by the
Knights were traders so here we have
rebirth but what about the part of smoke
and salt well in my opinion the wall
could represent the salt since it evokes
it stole that wall contains the salt
quoting from the books the doors upper
lip brushed against the top of Brandt's
head and drop of water fell on a man ran
slowly down his nose he was strangely
warm and salty as appear now this
sentence confirms the fact that the wall
is salty but could the salt of the wall
represent the salt in the prophecy well
it could in my opinion now let's try to
solve the small part since the prophecy
says that azor Ahai will be reborn amid
smokin salt
well the smoked part also came true do
you remember that well sanjay while she
performed erection ritual to bring John
back to life you remember the Mulsanne
jackal dog some chants here and tells
the curls into the flames after which we
saw the smoke so we got smoke as well
this is the only part of the prophecy
but this is not the only part that
matches to the prophecy it said that
brings the most promise should have the
blood of the dragon should be born of
the line of the Mad King Aerys Targaryen
and relative Aryan with John is John is
the son of Rhaegar Targaryen and
therefore his born of the line of arey
Sorella for in fact John's grandfather
and grandmother also in the show
adaptation who sure honors snow from
George Armour himself who is raha is its
real intent episode of season 6 that
John was born and her bleeding star
which fulfills the part of the prophecy
which says that princes promise will be
born and her bleeding star as we could
see Eddard Stark enter the Tower of joy
with the bloodied sword on the ancestral
sword which was forged from a fallen
star the stone covered in blood counts
yeah I think it does it's also important
to highlight a few other facts like for
an example when Melisandre looks into
the fire to see Ezra hi natsound Jones
see things related to erosion or snow
Jon Snow the second thing that is also
important to highlight is John's dream
that he dreamed in the books the dream
in which he fights the others the White
Walkers with red sword burning in his
head the only thing that John did not
achieve or at least not yet is awakening
dragons from the Stone I don't know if
all of this is only coincidence or John
is really azor Ahai reborn in the
promised prince but in my opinion
there's also possible
I am proof of azor Ahai being female
instead of male the prophecy was
originally made using the Valyrian word
for dragons which is neither male or
female
meaning that azor Ahai may be reborn as
a female as well let's see if Dany has
more matches to be azor Ahai let's focus
on possible proof that Danny is azor
Ahai the prophecy feeds Dany perfectly
she was born a gemstone an island in the
Narrow Sea meaning that we have the soul
from the waves hitting the shores of
jagged stone and also she was reborn as
the mother of dragons so Khal Drogo's
burning funeral bonfire which matches to
the part of the prophecy which includes
a mid smoke on that bonfire den is three
dragon eggs hatched which fits perfectly
in part of the prophecy which says born
amid smoke and salt awake dragons from
stone also very important fact is that
on that morning for the first time the
red comet appeared on sky which fits the
part it says when it starts bleed for
the final confirmation of Danny being
azor Ahai we have an additional prophecy
from the woods of which prophesied that
the prince that was promised to be born
frontline of Eris and raava as we all
know this prophecy also feeds Dany
perfectly since then is the daughter of
Ariston Rolla and similarly told to
Maester Aemon the rumors about dana
Targaryen energy agency emma became sure
that dan is the prophesied leader in the
book simon told to Sam no one ever
looked for a girl it was a prince that
was promised not a princess and also
told Sam that Dan is the chosen one born
amid smokin salt the Dragons prove it
yes the prophesied hero that will save
Westeros could be John or Danny however
I don't think any of the characters we
have in the current timeline is the
prophesied Savior I believe azor Ahai
was actually regular Targaryen whom fans
have ever heard of and finally saw in
season seven I'm sure you're wondering
doesn't the prince those promises have
to be live how will he defeat the night
king if he's dead well according to this
theory he'll defeat the knight in the
same way the original azor Ahai did with
his fabled weapon light bringer except
in this case light bringer is not a
sword but rather personname just now in
his youth Rhaegar Targaryen himself
actually believed that he was the
prophesied prince and so did his
great-great uncle Maester Aemon before
they both became convinced that the
sabre was actually rehearse and Aegon
instead
gregor I thought the smoke was from the
fire that evolved summerhall on the day
birth the soul from the tears shed for
those who died he shared my believin he
was young but later he became persuaded
that it was his own son who fulfilled
the prophecy for a comet had been seen
about King's Landing on the night a gun
was conceived in Rhaegar was earned the
bleeding star had to be a comet what
fools ever we thought ourselves so wise
said Maester Aemon in a fierce rock
routes in case you don't know Rhaegar
was born in Targaryen summer place
summer home surely after Raiders birth
the palace was consumed by a great fire
which claimed the lives of King Aegon v
maester aemon's brighter the king's son
and heir and the Lord Commander of the
Kingsguard
the tragedy is one of the more
intriguing backstories in A Song of Ice
and Fire and given its unexplained
nature perhaps george RR martin has been
withholding details until the time of
Twister reveals have the tragedy of the
summer hall helps fulfill the prophecy
of azor Ahai namely that Danny's old
brother was literally born amid smoke
assault Israel Noah's raha is said to be
born amid smoke assault and as maester
aemon said Rhaegar Targaryen does
fulfill the prophecy he was born in
summer Hall on the very same day the
castle burned to the ground
so there's a smoke but what about salt
the day the Kingdom also lost the
current king at the time a prince and
the captain of the Kingsguard as maester
aemon pointed out those death did lead
to many tears and tears are salty an
additional prophecy from a boots which
prophesied that the prince was promised
will be born from the line of Prince
Ares sent Princess Rolla Rhaegar is the
son of Ariston relah
however the fact that Rhaegar became
convinced that his son had a role to
play in the prophecy may not be far off
the man had a brothers hair but he was
taller and his eyes were a dark indigo
rather than lilac egg on his set Obama
nursing a newborn baby in a great wooden
bed what better name for a king will he
make a song for him the woman asked he
has a song the man replied he is the
prince that was promised and he is this
a Song of Ice and Fire
that his vision of past in a Clash of
Kings of course fans know that the baby
Rhaegar was talking about was his first
son aegon but Aegon's life ended during
the sack of King's Landing and the
mountain smash his head against the wall
killed his sister a niece and her mother
alaya Martell as game of terms thought
as the prophecies can be tricky and
while Rhaegar had the basics right he
was off in two key way
he considered the wrong son to be the
prophesied prince and the right son is
not actually Prince but rather a weapon
ironically turns out that he was right
the first time
himself was azor Ahai all along
according to a legend azor Ahai had to
try three times before successfully
forging his flaming sword Lightbringer
entered the tent he realized he would
have to sacrifice the thing he loved the
most in this world to successfully
create a weapon he had to kill his
beloved wife Nissa Nissa who was said to
cry out in both anguish in ecstasy when
azor Ahai tempered the blade by driving
it into her heart
similarly johnston was Rhaegar Starchild
third attempt and this creation resulted
with the death of Reger's beloved wife
Lina Stark who could be heard by your
brother ater crying out in anguish in
ecstasy from inside the tower joy she
was giving birth to her son
so the samurais Rhaegar was born amid
smoke of salt he forged his ultimate
weapon on his third attempt and he'd
sacrifice his wife and John has since
become a little light bringer a sword of
fire most assume that the part about
light bringer means that the original
azor Ahai killed his lover with an
actual sword and the sacrifice that
imbued the sorbets enough magical power
that it could drive back the darkness
but don't you think that would be too
simple and too little
here are our high kills his lover with
his sword reference with George are more
unusual uses in his books by wielding
the power of the sword Rhaegar
ultimately created a new weapon forged
with a loving Vice card the end product
is a super weapon capable destroying the
xix for good instead of a magical
flaming sword this weapon is John
himself their clothes hidden throughout
the show about us true nature of light
bringers forging
George our Marne uses the image of
immense stabbing a woman with his sword
as a metaphor for an intimate
relationship elsewhere in the books
perhaps the most prominent example of
this would be a conversation between
Thea named Barbie Dustin in a dance with
dragons
Brandon loved this sword he loved to
hone it I want to sharp enough to shave
the hair from a woman Scott used to say
and have you allowed to use it a bloody
sword is a beautiful thing he told me
once at the end it turns out that while
fans have been eagerly waiting for the
relation of Westeros Savior death years
time has come and gone Rhaegar Targaryen
did not stab Liana to the heart because
he interpreted the azor Ahai prophecy
correctly the forging of libraries
furring to conceiving and birthing of a
child Rhaegar fulfilled his destiny may
he created a sword in the darkness why
bring her Jon Snow a few months ago I
found one more hint from the official
game trans history and lore series if
you look closely on this shot which is
part of HBO's histories and lore series
of short animated videos included in
blu-ray releases savage TV season of
Game drones evil notice arose above
Asura hiya Nissa Nissa got a billion izv
intros hinting the Liana was in fact
records Nissa Nissa Rhaegar was azor
Ahai as well no Lyanna stark was very
fond of blue bin two roses during the
tourney at Harrenhal Prince Rhaegar
named lien and the queen of love and
beauty
giving her a garland of blue roses in
the statue of the enitre tomb underneath
Winterfell is holding a garland of blue
winter roses in my opinion this rose
above azure high can be considered as a
hit a hint that's going favor to Rhaegar
being a straw hi Ileana being nice an
Eastsider Sanj on a gun being the
Lightbringer after all this show is
literally the Song of Ice and Fire the
mela rated Traeger composed that he
created his son who would go on to
become the weapon that will kill the
night king and save all of Westeros from
long night I'm curious to hear your
thoughts about the story in the comment
section down below
do you agree with this or do you think
someone else is destined to stay
Westeros from the long night let me know
and as always I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see you in the next one peace